[Music]
the salt of sierra
freshly cut grass danger
a sense of smell is something many of us
take for granted
but what if it wasn't there covert 19
infections often lead to a loss of smell
the impact can be serious fires may burn
unnoticed
covert survivors may lose interest in
eating or fall into a deep depression
let's look at the strange ways covert is
tied up with our noses and neural
networks
out of all the senses most people say
they could do without smell
but have you thought about the
consequences for your life and job
about sixty percent of those infected
with the coronavirus will have had
problems smelling or tasting
for karen steigliter falling ill with
covert 19 was a professional disaster
the 53 year old did not have severe
symptoms but was left unable to smell or
taste anything
as the owner of a confectionary shop she
needed to test the quality of her cakes
and chocolates
finish it spill and wine if i have a
glass of wine for example
and at the same time had to taste a
glass of vinegar i couldn't tell the
difference
vegeta both of them taste acidic
but i couldn't tell you which one is
vinegar and which is the wine
alessandro bozzato says her symptoms are
typical
smell loss occurs when the coronavirus
infects cells that support neurons in
the nose
he prescribes smell training as therapy
in which patients relearn prescribed
scents
such as those of roses and lemons
after losing their sense of smell
patients can do this smell training to
stimulate damaged nerve cells
and start the process of healing or
regeneration
current styleglider has been using four
different scents a day to reactivate her
sense of smell
coffee cinnamon chocolate cloves or
vanilla are her favorite fragrances
it's a slow process but she hopes smell
training will bring back her ability to
smell and taste things
and let's talk about losing your sense
of smell with neuroscientist
rachel hers what i'd like to know first
of all is
if it could be permanent
so smell lots with cobin 19 we really
don't know what permanent means
so it's only been about a year or so
that we've been into this crisis
and it's certainly the case that with
upper respiratory tract infections smell
loss occurs but there's hope
for regaining it in those conditions and
i think that probably will be the case
here as well and there are different
methods that can facilitate that
especially things like smell training
some people have been experiencing this
though for months and months and months
i mean a year can be a long time how
traumatic can that experience
be emotionally and psychologically
well it's extremely traumatic and one of
the problems being i mean this idea of
permanence how long
is it going to last is it going to be
forever you don't know and so that
uncertainty even adds more to it
and it's very traumatic to lose your
sense of smell which people
unfortunately don't realize
because our sense of smell is connected
to everything people assume it's just
connected to can i smell the fire or the
gas
you know danger or the pleasure of food
but actually it's connected to
our emotional life in very intense ways
it's connected to our social life it's
connected to our personal intimacy
it's connected to our sense of self and
our memories and our sense of where we
are in the universe
with respect to other people on the
whole world so it can be extremely
ungrounding and very very
disturbing for people to lose their
sense of smell so rachel
is this a side effect of something
neurological
so with copen19 what seems to be going
on
is that the sars kobe 2 virus needs to
enter cells in order to
infect the host that is the human and
the
nose has a patch called the olfactory
epithelium
that's where olfactory sensory neurons
are where we detect smells
also contains two other kinds of cells
basal cells and what are known as
supporting cells
and these supporting cells have a high
number of the kind of
enzyme that's needed for the spike
protein of the sars kobe 2 virus to
enter in
this ace2 receptor people may be hearing
about
so the virus can bind very easily to
these cells and what happens is
it causes disruption and creates
inflammation which seems to be the
reason why
the olfactory sensory neurons shut down
because that's where we're normally
detecting smells
and then that's the first port of entry
into the rest of the body
so that's the basic mechanism so one of
the things i have a kind of a pet peeve
about
is people really need to cover their
nose with their mask because
that's the primary route of entry for
the stars virus to get into you
yep just came across one of those
colleagues in the corridors before
tell us when does this happen this this
loss of sense of smell is
is it an early symptom as some
healthcare workers have experienced
before even testing positive
i mean it could be a great warning uh in
stopping the spread of the disease just
like you were saying
warnings of of a bad smell of the fire
of gas
yes so what we've been involved in i've
been involved in research that was uh
conducted with yale healthcare workers
and what we found was actually
that disturbance in the sense of smell
preceded getting a positive
test by the pcr you know normal method
of detecting
you know biologically whether or not
you've been infected by two whole days
so this is actually a tremendous finding
that smell loss precedes
getting a positive diagnosis and also
precedes sort of feeling
sick in other ways and actually is
involved in about 86 percent
of people who feel very mild symptoms or
could otherwise be
asymptomatic so having smell loss is a
very very important signal
to the individual to first of all get
tested and secondly to self-isolate to
quarantine themselves then because
you want to be avoiding transmitting it
into the population
so if you can self quarantine at the
first sign of noticing smell loss that's
really important and not only smell loss
but also
altered smell what's known as porosmia
so smelling things but they don't smell
right
one person said to me everything smelled
like vinegar and so that's also
something that's a really important
signal
early warning sign of coca-19
and we saw that in about a third of the
people who reported smell dysfunction in
our study
i believe it's also a signal of
alzheimer's of parkinson's disease
but is it also a symptom of the new
cohort variants
so just to clarify the parasnia the
altered sense of smell is not really
so much as far as we know involved in
alzheimer's or parkinson's disease and
those things
where smell loss occurs that is decades
before we see
other symptoms but you ask a really good
question about the other variants
and i have to say that i don't know the
answer to that yet there
hasn't been any research that i've seen
that specifically looked at
what variant of the covid virus is
causing or the stars virus rather that's
causing the illness and whether or not
and how that's connected to smell loss
that's a great question i unfortunately
don't know the answer to that yet
like so many questions in this crisis my
last question can you
fully retrain your sense of smell
so the good news is that because of the
fact that it's an upper respiratory
tract infection that causes smell loss
you haven't had
neurological damage to the way that the
neurons can get into the brain
for detecting smell and so forth so
generally speaking in these cases there
is hope for recovery
and the best method to date is actually
exercising your nose where what you want
to do is
get a set of very distinctive smells so
things that smell really different or
that you remember smell really different
like lemon
or mint and you know some maybe perfume
or cloves and things like that and smell
those scents
multiple times per day smell each for
like about 10 seconds
and repeat that over and over let's say
three or four times per day for about
three months and then switch to another
set
and the good news is that although it's
not 100
effective many people start to see
improvement
in their ability to smell through doing
this sort of smell training
exercising of your nose so there is real
hope you know and it doesn't take that
long it's just like i said
you know a few minutes a couple of times
a day
and just have to keep up with it and it
seems what's happening there is it's
both
training your brain and potentially
causing your
receptors to become re-stimulated again
reactivated to
bring in more ability ability to
actually smell
great advice there from neuroscientist
rachel hurst thank you very much for
being on the show today thank you very
much for having me
over to derrick williams now our science
correspondent has been looking into your
questions on the coronavirus
[Music]
does the immunity you acquire from the
vaccine vary from person to person
[Music]
yes it does vaccines never provide
100 protection although a few that we've
developed
for other infectious diseases have come
close
but but everyone's immune system is
different
and will respond to particular vaccines
in individual ways trials showed that
even after being vaccinated
some people who were exposed to sars
cov2
ended up contracting symptomatic covet
19.
but the vaccines being distributed now
have proven to be pretty effective
at preventing symptoms caused by most
variants
in most people and and some vaccines
have proven extremely effective
at doing so um a simplified way of
putting it
would be to say that trials in some
vaccines
showed unvaccinated people were nearly
20 times
more likely to develop symptoms of
covid19
during the trial than someone who got
vaccinated
but the really interesting point is that
in trying to
return to something like normal vaccines
don't actually have to prevent covet 19
in everyone if they can just stop
symptomatic disease
in most of us that would ease the strain
on health systems
and what would be even better is if
vaccines could help slow
or stop transmission of the virus so if
they
not only prevent the disease in most
people but also
keep people from catching it having no
symptoms
and spreading it subsequently
unknowingly
there's new evidence that with at least
one approved vaccine
that's the case that aspect really is
key
because it would break infection chains
um to do that right now
we're still relying mostly on on blunt
instruments like like masks
and lockdowns and finally
there are strong indicators that even if
you do catch covet 19
after getting the shot at least some of
the vaccines are
limiting its severity so in other words
the people who get the disease even
after being vaccinated
rarely end up in hospitals
so listen to your nose thanks for
watching stay safe and see you again
soon
[Music]